Trane's heading for a tunnel up ahead
let's treat them at the station
future of our world is at stake you have
a mission how do I look fresh
is this normal pretty much go higher
further
go faster not to show these boys how we
do it
captain barb oh no you're going right
this film contains scenes that may be
too intense for younger viewers hey
everybody its charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Captain Marvel Super Bowl
trailer footage to break down so let's
do it there's a new brand of the Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Captain Marvel moment on the video you
probably spotted some super deep cuts
for the Captain Marvel Comics if you're
a big longtime fan of the character also
talk about what's going on with the
supposed Avengers in-game trailer that's
gonna drop during the Super Bowl in what
samuel l.jackson was saying about her
time traveling in the MCU so first big
part we get a longer version of the
scene where Captain Marvel is fighting
the Scrolls on the Los Angeles train
this time on top like we've seen
versions of this footage in the other
trailers she's fighting a dude on top of
the trailer so it's not clear whether or
not it's the exact same scroll that was
impersonating the little old lady that
she keeps fighting in the other scenes
[Music]
but it's all part of this longer train
sequence like we see her walk into the
depot looking around and then you get
the slam cuts to her punching the old
lady it's all an early part of the film
before Nick Fury really gets to know her
so we get some actual Coulson dialogue
where he's like head this way and
nickers I don't know we'll catch him at
the station that's probably this scene
here where he comes up on her and tries
to find out why it is she's going around
punching little old ladies because
remember at this point in the film he
doesn't know anything about scrolls
being shapeshifters so it looks like
she's really just going around punching
old ladies in trying to fight regular
commuters on the Los Angeles train there
was a moment during that last video I
posted about the pager where they're
kind of fumbling with it and it says
with target right now the pager is
talking about Captain Marvel she is the
target in the early part of the film
before do they find out the truth of
what's going on in Nick Fury's like wait
a minute so you're telling me scrolls
can look like anybody so when she first
arrives on earth for like that first
brief part before Nick Fury actually
starts to get to know her she is
technically their antagonist even though
she's the hero of the movie there's a
big burning plot line in the movie about
false identity false memories people
remembering their past finding out that
people have been lying to you so all the
character relationships are a little
mixed up when the movie picks up because
she thinks that she's a Kree Nick Fury
thinks this is some kind of
serial killer going around trying to
kill innocent people in the nick fury's
boss who's Talos the scroll tries to use
shield and turn Nick Fury against her
and treat her more like the enemy when
really she's been misled this whole time
and rediscovers her identity it wants to
help get rid of both the scrolls and the
Kree with the help of Nick Fury so even
though they seem pretty earnest I think
they're supposed to be a lot of funny
moments with them treating each other
like enemies when the movie picks up
until they really figure out what's
going on then there's a scene of her
with Monica Rambeau as a little kid huge
Captain Marvel comic book Easter Egg in
confirming that Monica Rambeau
is a character in the MCU there was some
earlier footage that I talked about in
my last video but it was kind of blurry
so it wasn't absolutely confirmed but
this just absolutely confirms it because
they're at her mother's house Maria
Rambo her former Air Force copilot so
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs in
this really short brief scene here one
it confirms that she remakes her crease
star force green uniform into the
classic Captain Marvel comic book
costume at Maria Rambo's house with her
friends help but on top of that it's
also probably where she truly
rediscovers her full backstory reclaims
her identity as Carol Danvers because up
to this point in the movie before she
remembers who she is the Kree just
referred to her as vers as in like
danvers with the dan cut off because
this is actually kind of a funny Easter
Egg for earlier in the film when she
gets into the accident with a psyche
magnetron and gets blown up effectively
and is lying there loses her memory part
of her dog tag gets broken so the Kree
find her with the broken dog tag that
only reads vers so they assumed that
that's what her name is and that's just
what they call her when she's at Marea
Rambo's house looking through all those
pictures and you have the other part of
the dog tag
she probably puts them together and it's
the light bulb on above her head like oh
wait a minute my name is Carol Danvers
and that's really when the things start
to click in her mind and she remembers
her real backstory the other really big
easter egg too is that if you look at
young Monica Rambeau here she's wearing
a very Captain Marvel comic book
inspired design t-shirt which is a super
deep cut for the comics because Monica
Rambeau is the original female Captain
Marvel not Carol Danvers it is the
weirdest most complicated continuity but
what happened is is that Carol Danvers
was first called mist
marvel for the longest time in the
comics they didn't start calling her
Captain Marvel until the early 2010's
quick history lesson back in the 60s and
the 70s Marvel wanted to kill off the
male
Captain Marvel Marvel but because they
didn't want DC Comics to yoink back the
Captain Marvel name from them so that
they could call Shazam Captain Marvel
again they had to give the Captain
Marvel name to another character that
was in an ongoing title like they had to
bookmark it essentially by saying hey
you you're the new Captain Marvel
because we need to keep this in
circulation
so during amazing spider-man annual
number six Monica Rambeau got powers and
just all of a sudden decided to call
herself Captain Marvel that's who they
gave the name to and at that time Carol
Danvers was still known as Miss Marple
so this is way back during the 70s
Monica Rambo's powers were really energy
manipulation but here's where it gets
weirder her comic book origin had
nothing to do with the original male
Captain Marvel she had no connection to
him she wasn't his friend she never
really interacted with him that much and
her powers didn't work anything like his
or miss Marvel's at all so it was more
of a legal reason for Marvel Comics to
give her that name than a reason that
made sense for her character later what
they did to try and fix that continuity
problem though is is they introduced the
genes-- Val character and gave him the
Captain Marvel name because they wanted
to give it to someone who had an actual
connection to the original male Captain
Marvel so he took the name from Monica
Rambeau in Monica Rambeau started
calling herself Photon and obviously
that is the connection to Maria Rambo in
the air force here whose callsign is
Photon so what they're telling you here
is is that Monica Rambeau will probably
be a hero in the future inspired by
Carol Danvers here a superhero like wow
you look pretty fly I want to be a
superhero too someday
so even if she doesn't get powers it
just sounds like she will be a character
in present day as an adult they'll have
to recast with a new actress but somehow
she'll be able to help Captain Marvel
with whatever the plot of the Captain
Marvel sequel is and then you know maybe
they'll decide to give her powers who
knows whatever they do with the Monica
Rambeau character they'll just save that
for the sequel which I think at this
point is a foregone conclusion but it's
still gonna be a couple years away so
they're probably not gonna start talking
about that till the movie comes out
because you got to know the people that
are going to be interviewing them for
this or gonna ask
about Monica Rambeau like are you
intending to set her up is she gonna be
a big face for character and present-day
usually what Marvel says for stuff like
that is they're like yeah anything is
possible like even if they haven't
absolutely locked down the story for
what the Sikh was going to be they
probably have an idea for what they
would do with her character here's the
thing about samuel l.jackson saying the
Captain Marvel can time travel though he
said that during an interview and it
sounded like an offhanded remark samuel
l.jackson is a longtime comic book fan
so he does know his comics he's not
pulling that straight out of his ass or
anything like that but what I think he's
actually referring to is is the Captain
Marvel's powers give her the ability to
live way longer than other people they
kind of addressed that during another
trailer where the Kree supreme
intelligence played by a net benning's
character tells her we remade you you're
stronger you'll live longer so it
implies that she'll just age very slowly
the same way that Captain America
because of the Super Soldier Serum ages
very slowly I don't think that anybody
is gonna be quite like Thor though
Thor's 1500 years old still looks like
he's in his 30s but a lot of people just
heard samuel l.jackson say Captain
Marvel can time travel and assume that
that meant that she would literally
time-travel to present day for avengers
endgame and I don't think that's exactly
what's going to happen I think you just
go on living for the next 20 plus years
until the events of Avengers endgame
policing the Kree and scroll part of the
universe to make sure that their war
doesn't flare up again and threaten the
rest of the galaxy like she's protecting
earth in outer space using her full
powers so hopefully that provides some
context for that I know there's still a
lot of questions about the quantum realm
how they're going to use quantum energy
because that's an alternate means of
literally time-traveling because of the
time vortices in there and phase
shifting between realities like the
ghost does only on purpose whereas she
couldn't control it
until Janet Van Dyne wasp helped her out
a little bit but if you have more
questions about what's going on with the
mechanics or the Easter eggs that you
see and all these trailers just leave
them in the comments below and I'll try
to get to them this weekend obviously we
got crazy more Super Bowl trailers
Disney bought a whole bunch of Super
Bowl ads meaning that one of them is
probably going to be in Avengers and
game trailer they've already confirmed
that there's gonna be a Toy Story 4
trailer there might be a game of Thrones
Season 8 trailer then after that it's a
mixed bag there could be a couple other
surprises if there are other big one
that were not announced I will totally
make videos for them leave your requests
in the comments below I'll name a
giveaway winner when I post a new Marvel
video so just look out for that click
here for that other brand new different
Captain Marvel trailer and click here to
learn all about why Ben Affleck is not
going to be Batman in the next Batman
film thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]